July 1st I tweeted this picture of my
Instagram Explorer feed and of course
the internet went absolutely insane
who's gonna tell him kill yourself
[__] bro got clapped by Community
notes 70 million views and Counting
everyone calling me a porn addict trying
to teach me how the social media
algorithms work
let's break it all down
the virality behind this tweet is the
irony tweeting how an Explorer feed full
of softcore porn is Haram when basically
everyone and their mother knows the
Explorer feed shows you what you
interact with and want to see I know
what you're thinking we got you Sunny
you're a porn addict no you didn't let
me explain how the algorithm actually
works since I know for a fact I
understand it better than every single
one of you to understand the algorithm
you first need to understand the motives
of the founders if I ask you what's the
main goal of these social media
companies I'm assuming most of you would
say to make money of course
wrong the actual main goal of these
social media companies is to keep you
scrolling as long as possible so they
can collect your data and control your
mind
not everything is for money like a lot
of you guys think you can literally
watch unlimited porn for free do you
really think PornHub and these sites are
making all their money from Ron Jeremy
ads popping up on the side
hot grandmas one mile away
down to [__]
wrong again it's intentionally free so
they can keep you weaker and easier to
control man gotta be men and they can't
wear dresses then what do they do push
softcore porn onto children to get them
addicted at a young age ruin their minds
and push the agenda that masturbating is
good for you
what Google the number one ESG score in
the country telling you that
masturbating once or more per day is
normal and healthy remember if it's free
you're the product I never head out
without my New York City tap water okay
so now we're coming to the same page
that the world is run by satanic
billionaires who Implement strategies to
keep us weak and controlled the same
people who own big Pharma music your
Bank Media your brain what's their next
step in The Jerk mind control attack the
vulnerable consciousness
these companies recognize there are soft
spots in men's Consciousness which they
can invade to keep you on their
platforms for longer after that first
Haram tweet I decided to prove this
point by moving from Instagram to tick
tock I made a brand new account with the
intention of making the for you page all
women as quickly as possible for all the
retards that are saying that I don't
understand the social media algorithms
I'm going to curate this for you page to
titties within five minutes two seconds
later we haven't even been [__]
scrolling for two seconds
and we already have three women in a row
so let me make something clear to you if
you like one softcore porn video on Tick
Tock you don't even need to like it if
you just watch until the end the next
scroll is more boobs than with two more
Scrolls your whole for youth page is
tatas there is no other niche in the
world where it's this easy to curate
your for you page you have to actively
work to keep titties off your feed when
you want to make your feed gym and
motivational speakers you have to scroll
for hours only liking every Tate video
you see have you heard of the based
mother instant scrolling past all the
other garbage bookmarking every W post
just to get to the point where your feed
can maybe be thirty percent motivational
why because this doesn't fit their
agenda you watching pubg doesn't keep
you weak and easy to control so they ban
suppress that content and make it a
thousand times more difficult to make
that your for you page but when you
double tap a couple girl girls
you get lit up with hoes because they
know it's a weak spot in the man's
Consciousness boy when you finally say
goodbye though it's real nice
oh my God
[Music]
I knew I'd quit jerking my penis the
funniest thing about blowing up like
this is I don't even watch porn was that
actually my explore feed yes
I'm not gonna deny that what was I
looking at right before the Tweet must
have been females I'm not denying that
or maybe I was dming some girls none of
you guys would understand did I only
screenshot the feed because it's not
usually like that so it being all
titties looked ridiculous
yes at least I'm not pretending like
everyone else on Twitter I never have
titties on my feed I have
apparently I'm the only person on all of
Twitter who's had this issue where you
make a new account and softcore porn is
shoved down your throat where you like
one picture of a girl you know and
follow and now
I'm honestly surprised people didn't
pick up on the troll by the second tweet
where I legit had one of the videos
liked on the for you page just goes to
show how brain dead 99 of the population
is when scrolling on social media
however this is a good thing for us
marketers because it makes it easier to
tap into the NPC Consciousness and get
millions of views whatever we make fun
of fish for eating food with a hook but
it's never been easier to bait a twee
[__]
maybe that's why they call me
the master Bader
[Music]
jokes aside I know the inside and outs
of going viral there's basic formulas
you copy and paste to get millions of
views whether it's something stupid like
this or business idea to bring in
millions for those of you who want to be
on the winning side of the scrollers I'm
launching a completely free newsletter
where I'll be dropping daily tips on
these fundamentals of going viral how to
get millions of views and how to
monetize since that's what I've been
doing full time for basically three
years now anyone looking into getting
the social media or online money game I
would definitely recommend joining just
to get some free extra tips or don't I
don't really care regardless free value
emails are going out daily
with that
au revoir
Link's at the top of the description by
the way
[Music]